Hello and welcome to this video where we will be going through exercise two.
For this we will be using the noise stimulus to detect a noise and have an ARA run towards it.
But back in the engine what I would like you to do is come to the slide number two here
which is exercise two noise stimulus. Now if I hit simulate what you're seeing is we have a small
system here where these explosive barrels are getting dropped at random between these different
areas. What I'd like to do with this is make it so that the NPC character here will be able
to detect it and move towards it. Now what I'm going to do is open up the state tree so that
we can have a quick look. And again this is very similar to the last one we were looking at.
We have an out of combat section at the top where we just set the character to wander about
and in the second section we have a heard something and going to investigate that and
wait for one second until returning back to the root. And the way that we are communicating
with this state tree you can see on the left hand side here is we have an evaluator for
e-hearing and all this is going to be doing is this is going to monitor two different
variables a boolean if you've heard something and the location that the noise came from.
Okay so now let's have a quick look at the AI noise. Now for this we already have the
perception update set up for us and you can see that this is relatively similar to what we were
previously doing. We are looking on target perception updated and we'll update as that
comes through. For this we are checking for the class stimulus and we use the AI sense
hearing in this case. If this is true we are going to know something has heard and we are
going to have a we're going to set the location on the stimulus location. So it's a very simple
script similar to what we did in the last exercise. You'll also see that we have an event
to reset these two values and that we will trigger just once the AI has approached and
got to it. Okay now so where do we need to put the actual code? In this case you will see
that there is a BPNoiseMaker. Now what I'd like you to do is open this up and have a look
and it has primarily one piece of code. What this does is when the
when the component is hit the cylinder it will turn on a particle effect,
hide everything, play a sound at the location, wait one second and then destroy the actor.
So it's relatively straightforward. Now we only need to do one extra thing to get this to work
and we talked about this previously but in song stimuli you are going to need to
manually report when you want it to be triggered and this is one of those cases.
So what I'm going to do is drag off after the play sound and location
and I'm going to type in reportNoiseEvent and that's going to give us this
noise here. I'm just going to use the actor location to plug that in and that is all the
code that I need you to do at this point. Apart from one thing we need to set a maximum
range. For this I'm going to set this in as 3000. I'm going to compile and save.
You'll see that we also have a loudness. This acts as a multiplier for the range
so if you change that to two that would make the range an equivalent of 6000
and it just allows you to have two different controls and you can change.
Then the last thing I need to do is I need to note down the instigator.
Before that I'm just going to grab the reference to self and plug that into the instigator.
You can now see that once the noise is reported the character is alerted to it
and will move to the find location. If we were to have a quick look at how the
AI perception component is set up, again in this case we have a sets config that we've set up as
the AI hearing and we are setting it up as a hearing. Our hearing range I've set to a very
long distance and again detection by affiliation has increased and making sure it starts in
neighborhoods. That's all that we need to do in order to get this up and running.
That brings us to the end of this video on using noise stimulus.
Next up we're going to be doing a quick example using touch.